his elbow in the right place so let's
look at it just structures I need his
body to be cheap in that relationship to
where his elbow is to see that do you
guys see that if it's here like that is
not inch pocket okay so I need this
angle this body relationship at a
minimum now I parked at his face so he
walks back we rewind the film she sing
so I wait for his elbow now I like his
body keep going and leave the elbow
there there he goes
then I don't push on this elbow there
you go like this see in doubles in front
and now I pushing it back I live there
as you come in and then I send this out
later
then his elbow will be in the right
place his face and that's where he hits
my mouth so he comes in you see I'm
doing that
[Music]
now you condition of them as I maintain
structure or the back you do this you
did it again you push it is elbow
let's have me come forward around don't
clash with it and then you just same way
don't clash with his elbow you made it
too close to you they're not even gonna
push it back out make this stuff fit
okay let's go
well the assumption is that you will
have enough mass or force generated in
space-time
if you energy go out it will not work
that mass will override the movies will
continue
superior Maskull stop that okay so if
you I don't know maybe in the kids class
ever notice you can kind of you kind of
get everything on the kids because
you're way stronger than that there is a
force output component to all I kielbasa
so if we watch our farm
you're letting energy out in some very
common ways okay so these are this I
disconnected my my hips and my shoulders
now I'm going to some other ones are you
adopt this angle look at this angle it
is it is more that ankle angle that is
the problem okay so some of you will get
your foot down but you still have that
ankle angle which is why I complain
about your arch not being alive or the
outside edge not being down the angle of
the back leg is here look at that angle
of my ankle do you see that not over
here like that so when I have energy I
don't mean what you guys think it can
happen remove this spirit do you see how
I did that so you can get the elbow in
that zero space fast directly you can do
a ten colony that's the bottom okay
so pay attention to your posture
organization this kill weight energy is
going to go this way because my boss is
going that way so I can't do this now
this right there's no ground path there
I can't do it
hips here no all that's not going to do
it okay
so if if if her elbow is hitting zero
I can make your worst nightmare come
true
okay but I just want you to come in and
I will throw you in with my team okay
let's go so you stopped him from coming
in and you go there's not gonna be
enough so you like this you see that and
now you pushed on it
so you want to next to me watch how much
she comes back past me you see watch how
I get in there the first movement is not
with my hand the first movement is I
matched him lick my weight shifting you
see weight shifting boom so you have to
let him go by you want him to go
[Music]
[Applause]
No
then the key one was that I have
subscribe admit you can to prescribe
movement so you know my prescription
well what is his prescription and how it
looks now
what so if I if I would finish here you
see what let's describe it like this
that looks into me
it's give in the weight shift in the
curve here in the out tights head and
then I go to a mom so if I'm doing it
what's he doing yeah so it has to stay
out there
and he doesn't go that way go that way
this makes no sense he sing so he has to
fit the puzzle so he's coming in he
keeps pushing me that's why I'm healed
that's how I'm able to bring his help
behind him secondly what 10 is the palm
heel strike look like to you yeah her
Yong Yong so he needs to go up with his
head again you see it doesn't bring his
head to me oh so he watches you Kenny
he's pushing when the strike comes you
see where it goes
[Music]
that's we're not going to trade slow our
whole line right and that first movement
is sheer Wow and you decide you ready to
take that okay so we're gonna go slow
the technique so that leg goes past me I
take this leg
oh you deconstructed him then I come and
take this out so this rotating is not
only not efficient
[Music]
there you go that's it that's it
okay so Yuki minute you went like
get ready for the battery that's all you
can say
and when we do gene what's up you think
you're gonna know something's up
you're not gonna do that you're not
gonna learn fall then you're not
learning what is likely going to happen
in a social violence please penetrate
practice territoriality right so when
you can stop yourself you're gonna do
all kinds of things so I stopped myself
so this the turn I don't like the term
okay softly and it won't let us practice
the elbow so keep practicing the elbow
also spiritually you don't you want to
not cheat that you see you want you you
got pregnant so you protected yourself
way to do technique you should release
yourself
Hey
just I'm going to practice this
surrender okay forget to touch just a
psychological drill look how my standard
keeps going till it can you see that I
keep this singular intention
you see that I'm going to keep that
rotation doesn't seem to work so I'm not
gonna go down steep down you see that
just like I'm not gonna see if I trying
to not penetrate
I joined of speed down in this
psychological experiment I keep going
into you see okay
hey can you see that you don't come in I
don't know you don't but it feels like
it doesn't it feels like but everyone
can see you're not coming so I'm going
to give you some obvious markers here
okay
he's standing on that X which is flying
line on that ass okay so if I do not
make my spine go to that X then I did
not embody a social aggression I'm I'm
not here what I do this see on stop so
watch watch the other you don't have to
you can be relaxed - so he I push watch
out for my dear do you have pasta so it
I know when you come from another style
that's what you usually see because
you're all getting ready for the back
rainfall you know I don't want you to
get regular we want you to do the
prescribed energy print that do gays
assigned and that is not this I keep
going in and I let myself be thrown not
I throw myself I keep going in
so that's why I watch you here's where
you normally want to go
hey my chin ado - step stay right where
you are I'm going to come out I'm gonna
do a whole step I want you to do half of
that okay I don't care which leg but you
have to end up here here and you let
yourself be from okay
and I can't experience my resistance my
rejection and then I can start to
practice acceptance okay let's try it
again we're working on her okay hey
she's coming in I know each already keep
going never
don't let your breath this time so I
have to go like this and she's doing the
drum so I'm here relax
that's how you get hurt you disengage
your Center as I walk yeah I'm gonna
lose it but you see it's not just
thinking so I don't go here and they not
go victim that everything is the tomten
is still engaged
you see okay